no solo no hay camas hospitalarias
disponibles ahora tampoco cuentan con
oxígeno los pacientes de kobe 19 en
india que requieren suministro del gas
vital están muriendo a causa del
desabastecimiento
no tienen vergüenza saben cómo muere un
humano sin oxígeno
han visto un pez sin agua más de 20
pacientes han muerto sufriendo así es
cera fox y dunkin de acm era para timar
a mi esposo murió por falta de oxígeno
ellos lo mataron y me dijeron que su
corazón falló como pueden morir 23
personas al mismo tiempo no nos dijeron
lo que había pasado se encargaban coches
carrera en el país ya no se habla de una
oleada sino de un tsunami de casos que
ha rebasado todas las proporciones
hospitales hacen llamados desesperados
para aumentar el suministro de oxígeno
los pacientes están muriendo a las
afueras de los centros de atención
mientras que el gobierno defiende su
gestión y envía aviones militares para
cargar tanques vacíos y así acelerar la
recarga y distribución fui a casi todos
los hospitales de ghaziabad todos me
dijeron que no tenían suministros de
oxígeno
vine aquí nos dijeron que nos fuéramos
porque no tienen oxígeno luego vinieron
y le hicieron una prueba de coronavirus
pero no le recetaron nada las directivas
hospitalarias han alertado que hay
cientos de pacientes en riesgo los
servicios funerarios también están
colapsados y piden a las personas que
esperen pese a que sus familiares llevan
días fallecidos la desesperación se ha
tornado la constante en una crisis que
podría requerir de meses para ser
superada